hey you guys
it's Monday yeah here's our side track
show just like we do I promise we were
gonna come back and talk to you every
day and we're still doing it yeah I went
down I went down did supply run went to
Sam's yeah yeah I had to wait in line
and then they all sent us in there
because they did they let you all go in
there in a big batch yeah this is all
right once I was in here was fully
supplied lots of meat lots of [ __ ]
fish got us some frozen shrimp some big
shrimp and yeah you made you got all ya
got a lot of meat little boxes a lot of
meat was on sale yeah yeah bread yeah a
lot of bread yeah so no problems with
that but they were just they were
letting people in like just bunches yeah
they let everybody back up
I guess just like so many people so you
can like right they were letting every
it kind of let about 30 people back up
and I guess they were what letting
people leave yeah and then they said
okay go in Disney World
once they were in once we were in there
though they weren't trying to keep us
contained yeah like you could go
wherever you want it to okay cuz then
Chris when you went before yeah hey
whatever I had to go down a route yeah
what they were doing cuz we went to
Publix a week or two ago and there
wasn't a line or anything cuz I think we
just went in the middle of the day so it
wasn't too bad but they were just
letting people in whenever but they had
all the aisles were one-way like you
could only let go that way through them
we could pass people like you weren't
supposed to pass people yeah but other
than that it wasn't really that big a
deal
I don't think and it seemed like they
were mostly supplied I didn't look I
didn't look into the paper aisle because
we have a [ __ ] ton of toilet paper still
but um Sam's had everything yeah sam's
club had ever like i said it looked like
you got and a lot of [ __ ] was on sale
got some of those damn beef beef short
ribs and a chicken pork tenderloin it's
on sale
he got everyone saying a peanuts you
know we bagged a shrimp yeah go bag a
flounder thank for it yes flounder it's
not a fillets Danny I love seafood yeah
and then got a bunch of those little
bags oatmeal that you like yeah got I
got so much Oh Bailey
yeah I'm like oh let's do big ol things
of cheese one for peach that one I was
helping you unpack but I have bigger
things to you so you know we're gonna be
good for two months I think I'll free go
back smash it freeze law freeze it you
know yeah yeah that's shrimp though that
shrimp down is down almost to where what
the prices were during the hurricane
really yes we might know how much of it
that big oil bag that we were normally
getting I think there was $13 or $12 oh
that's good yeah yeah I think when we
got it like during the hurricane they
were trying to get rid of it before
because they thought that power was
gonna go and I was like hey what it um
no I think it was $12.99 twelve okay
$13.99 it's a three pound bag in it yeah
about a five pound bag
I can't remember good shrimp there like
that yeah they're big like frozen frozen
raw shrimp you know we were doing we
were doing shrimp boil yeah throw in
some potatoes [ __ ] Old Bay seasoning
yeah for you guys that lift man there's
no [ __ ] cleaner source of damn animal
protein than to have shrimp tail that's
what we did man when we used to go to
koi one I would punish above go to that
Chinese buffet they had that [ __ ]
cold boiled shrimp laying out there I
punished them for putting a pounds of
shrimp no problem well that's the thing
about shrimp is like you could just you
can eat a lot of it and you seem like
you don't get full really like pure
protein there's no carbohydrates in it
it's really easy to digest it's very low
in fat it's it's it's like better than
that whey protein it's animal protein
yeah get a little bit cocktail sauce we
have some lemon juice on it
hell yeah yeah regretted letting me they
were like you get out I lost all their
profit margin well you had to leave some
for me because I want it but I can't
like a big huge pile of them I just see
like a few cuz when we would go to the
buffet I can only like May
be a plate and a half before I start
feeling like I'm going to throw up so
because I can't eat that much at once so
I just try to get like little bits of
every year when they have the pisser in
the evenings when we go on the evenings
at the crab legs up yeah I'll spend that
extra money for those crab legs and they
regret [ __ ] that [ __ ]
they regret it as my grandma used to say
I think you have a hollow leg yeah cuz
like all the food it's like Chinese
girls come out and they say mr. Oz we
regret to inform you that you must leave
you have eaten all the profit margin
every time to come we end up owing money
[Laughter]
like little shrimp shells and like we
make up for with the people that don't
eat it though see it's it's a it's a law
of averages because most people go there
and eat rice I won't get a [ __ ] not a
single grain of rice on a buffet well
yeah well we go there I tend to look
carbs well because it's it's too
fulfilling but I don't get any rice or
noodles I love noodles but it's like I
feel like I won't be able to eat that
much because noodles are like such a
filling thing and I can make those at
home any I'll get the pot stickers you
know that we know that I have those and
I have the damn what they call a [ __ ]
like a crab rangoon yeah I'll have those
just yeah I make those two they're good
there's another cream cheese cream
cheese [ __ ] can't cure I try to like
just have one of those because they're
real fattening it's all fair very
fattening yeah but I try to only have
like protein and vegetable you want beef
and peppers yeah you have to be pepper
steak stuff [ __ ] like that I try not to
get anything fried I get tempted by the
sushi though even though it's not great
sushi is just sushi it's I can I can
take sushi or leave it honestly we
haven't made sushi in a long time
no I haven't made it in a while it's a
cage to me it is a bit general all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] slices I mean we have the
mats and everything it's just so much
more you know Publix yeah you can just
buy a line and a plastic thing if they
make it every nice fresh yeah yeah yeah
they make it in the [ __ ] sea for yeah
I think like every day so you just get
it in there yeah they got Chinese girls
and Vietnamese girls back there making
it yeah that's just me
get it at the dancing yeah but I'll have
Japanese people make it is Chinese
public says I mean they've got really
good [ __ ] all the other fish is good
like all they're like deli stuff is good
like their sandwiches are amazing yeah
they're fried chicken is really good
Sushi's good their bakery is incredible
I get like you I got your birthday cake
they're like last few years I think
Publix ice cream they have their own
they have their own dairy and their own
ice cream making facility their [ __ ]
store brand is better than any of it the
only thing that kind of closely
challenges it was Blue Bell I kind of
love Bluebell and Publix is on par with
that although Blue Bell you can tell
there's a lot of heavy cream in it the
way that ice cream stretches well yeah
you know that's real southern [ __ ]
ice cream right yeah I mean if you're
gonna if you're gonna go for the
calories you might as well other ice
cream is banned in Mississippi there's
only way again there's only Blue Bell
every [ __ ] corner store has it yeah a
little
well they if they have it pretty much
here everywhere - I think I think even
like in the [ __ ] refrigerated part of
Walgreens and [ __ ] like that I think
they got some flavors and they're just
normal if you're if you're in Europe you
know your England or in Australia
there's a brand we have here called
Bluebell
it's us I think it's almost pretty much
owned it I think the dairy is in the
south and it's a southern comment i i'm
gonna be curious if people in other part
of the US if they sold it up there or
not because i'm pretty sure i mean it's
kind of a go back 25 years 30 years i
can remember the existence of blue belt
it was in it was [ __ ] heavy in
mississippi and yes that's what they
preferred if it wasn't that they
wouldn't even buy it all that
haagen-dazs [ __ ] and ben and jerry's
[ __ ] they won't touch it I mean they're
like they'll buy it but that's like
underneath Bluebell yeah and booba has a
lot of flavors but they're they're
traditional flavors like vanilla wafers
and bananas I love that one yes like
banana pits called banana daily good
banana pudding I think
about three different kinds of chocolate
they got about three or four different
kinds of vanilla and strawberries and
it's all fresh stuff and it's just when
the ice cream its it stretches yeah it
doesn't break a stretch is like a GU
yeah which that's a sign a lot of eggs
and a lot of damn cream yeah it has like
yeah it comes like in a plastic bucket
yeah I used to come in a paper bucket
yeah our wax paper yeah but now it's
plastic yeah they they actually have
like a really like vast array of flavors
because I think last time we were
looking at ice cream which is a long
time ago but I was looking at all the
Bluebell flavors and yeah and it and
it's a very plain-looking packaging and
it was not expensive yeah it's not one
of the little fancier it was just local
and the quality was I'm very very high I
thought it was like something like one
of the Carolinas or maybe something like
in Virginia it was it was a it was I
think on this side of the mason-dixon
because it's kind of like sometimes it's
weird to think about because I mean I
grew up in Florida and [ __ ] like that
but it's weird to think about that even
in some parts of the US
you know brands that are like ubiquitous
here yeah they don't have them you know
what I mean and you know there's usually
reasons for that like I said you know we
talked about Publix all the time they
don't have those
there's distribution stuff there's
certain laws were throughout West like
for a while Yuengling beer was illegal
in certain states it was yeah okay yeah
because my my sister's ex-husband he
loved Yingling and every time he came to
Florida to visit his family he always
bought a bunch and took it back in the
car because they didn't sell it they
lived in Denver and they didn't sell it
out there for whatever reason even
though I think that beers from Boston I
think it is yeah I guess from here I
know it's I think it's the nation's
oldest brewery or might have been Philly
because he was from Philly okay and he
was very Philly proud you know what I
mean it was good bigger than that that
black and tan beers there was really
good yeah I'm a black beer it's like a
stout and SH it was really good it was
cheap yeah it's not expensive beer no
it's not the quality is just very high
very high for what you're getting you
know for what you pay
you're like damn I'm not a big beer
drinker it's like and I feel like yang
Ling was probably one of the first ones
that I could actually drink enough of to
get a buzz off of yeah because I don't
like beer all that much I mean so I
didn't really drink it I was more hard
like her person but it's like you know
some places that we went like when we
used to go to some of the smaller venues
around here that didn't have like a
liquor license and they could only sell
beer you know what I mean then I would
get I would usually get maybe this is
gross but I would usually get like
flavored beers like I like coffee beers
or like vanilla
so that microbrews like vanilla stout
stuff like that it's like every time
like I watched beer and board games and
like somehow like the other day they had
because they're still doing the show
even though they're all like quarantine
so they have to do it like in four
different rooms but they had like a they
have a different beer every time in the
one they had last time I think it was
like a peanut butter beer yeah the one
guy Matt look [ __ ] horrified because
he's like he hates that got a beer but
I'm like that kind of sounds good well
you know microbrewery stuff came in in
the 90s and I was in the army yeah it's
starting to get big you know and it was
like hipster before they were hipster I
stroke
never bringing in all kinds of new [ __ ]
like and there was one good brand they
head up in Boston I liked it's called
Sam Adams I don't like yeah they saved
all that everywhere and even had Sam
Adams bars where you know they had [ __ ]
on tap I don't know if that still exists
but you could there was brewery bar you
know and I don't remember what it
exactly what it was called but actually
I might be getting I might be getting
confused I think that was a some kind of
a house type chain that they had up
there and you can get a bunch of that
stuff Sam Adams on tap it's been so long
but they had this stuff they come out in
the winter all this wind all these
winter flavors like cranberry lambic and
[ __ ] like that yes like crap that kind
of sounds like I thought like a
cranberry flavor cuz like I said I'm not
a big I don't really like beer I don't
really like choose it but some of the
ones that are like flavored a
particularly like the wintery or the
fall ones I like those used to take the
cranberry lambic and pour it into the
[ __ ] Stout put it into a black beer
yeah drink out gather there's good well
in that like I said when you used to get
those snakebite lines like that because
you would
get Guinness and then they had like a
pear cider
yeah they mix it all together that was
really good yeah pear yeah that's right
yeah because they didn't always have it
because they have yet different flavor
insiders but the pear when I think
what's the best yeah apples better but
pear works too
yeah pears and apples er yeah tastes
similar so what else
Oh what did we do last night we watched
Friday the 13th part five yeah yeah
we've been working our way through all
the Friday's I've seen the motion at
various times shutter has one through
eight I believe are one through nine so
we were like last night we'd already
watched like one movie two that we're
gonna review for the matinee show and
then we're like hey let's watch another
Friday 13th it's like I don't really
have to pay that much attention to it
was five right five yeah okay we've
reviewed well four is a lot of people's
favorite out of the series on to is
actually my favorite but I can see why
for what I mean four is a really good
one and and and three wasn't bad I like
three - actually I'm gonna say one
through five actually I they weren't
that bad five was not as good as the
other ones but it wasn't that bad
more like a parody yeah it was like a
comedy almost kind of like a parody of a
Friday the 13th kind of in the way where
you know escape from LA is kind of like
a parody yeah that's a good of escape
from me Carol I kind of like that as
long as you're not taking Friday the
13th real seriously as long as you're
not religious about it we're like that
is not canon you know where's the you
know where's Jason yeah where's a random
dude yeah if you were if you were into
like continuity this would piss you off
well if you're into continuity you
probably shouldn't be watching the
Friday drive well I can harbor I saw
this one when it came out it came out in
85 and I remember it didn't remember
anything about it really
I just remembered not liking it yeah and
I've seen it again I can understand why
I didn't like it back then a little
veiny it's zany yeah and it it
the story was [ __ ] up it wasn't really
graphic really at all really weird how
tame they are those movies and I don't
know if it
just because a lot of the gore gets cut
out this movie this is the one it seems
to me that they were mad that they had
to cut some of the gore out so they said
well we'll make up for it by putting in
more tits and more swearing because
pretty much every other word was [ __ ]
this and [ __ ] that
and that Everett pretty much every woman
in the movie life had to show her tits
like which didn't quite work which
didn't quite work for me yeah and I
don't think it was working for me back
when I saw this in 85 yeah because the
tits that they did add they were
better-looking women but there wasn't
anything kind of like a CD about it
the other ones kind of had a CD mystic
this one was a little it was just coke
inspired hilari and there was screaming
and there's coke in the movie yeah of
coke in the movie and a lot of druggie
and it's not really realistic at all you
don't really get scared at all in it you
know I wouldn't been scared back then
it's kind of the new dee dee was just
kind of kind of generic the girls were
just kind of generic you know most of
them exception of it was is that the
there's a goth girl in there that's very
accurate to the time yeah she's wearing
exactly a lot of [ __ ] that I remember
the big old [ __ ] skirt was like a
damn potato sacks yeah they used to wear
them [ __ ] things that didn't fit she
[ __ ] wearing those [ __ ] funny ass
flat pants trying to hide her [ __ ]
fat booty tying a sweater around her
waist at the hair and the makeup and the
[ __ ] tops that she was wearing it was
just right out of [ __ ] high school
yeah that was a nice man I was in junior
high it looks like I dated that girl
yeah the [ __ ] maid you go back and
look at it this is the problem a lot of
times in these movies from the 80s when
they would show any kind of punk rocker
and he kind of goth or anything like
that you could tell it was a costume
yeah that is not what we were [ __ ]
wearing yeah alright and and what the
[ __ ] that they did where they would be
wearing it in an inappropriate time or
they'd be wearing it in a way that
[ __ ] you could tell that that dude
it wasn't but this girl you could tell
either whoever dressed her up or who or
maybe she did her makeup or her so she
knew what she was doing
yeah it did I mean it looked like I knew
girls that looked like a success
you know she didn't know how I was in
junior high she didn't know how to dance
which makes me think she was doing the
robot she's doing the [ __ ] robot and
we didn't do the [ __ ] robot dad so
that made me think that somebody told
her to dance like that
yeah yeah yeah somebody told her to
dance like that
or so we just told her to dance and she
did not a dance because the makeup
artists in the wardrobe knew what goth
kids wore also didn't she have an Alan
Parsons Project yeah yes like that's not
I guess that's not totally weird but it
is a little bit his way out of place I
mean she did have I like some prog rock
too but I wouldn't have that an Alan
person I think what it was is the the
director he putting his favorite bands
probably most of the other posters
looked okay a business he had it looked
like Sex Pistols one I think she had
like a Madonna one yeah it looked like
85 like a lot of kind of goth girls like
like Gia's that was still when Madonna
was a little bit looked like she had a
poster of Elvis Costello when he was
young I think that was all that no
really that it was the guy no no that
was that was a keyboard player from
fucus Eagles that's right yes the flock
of seagulls with that okay that's rise
right that's good yeah cuz I was really
into fun riding because I remember that
those glasses that's right yes you
didn't you recognise him that was yeah
it was bought it was bothering cuz you
kept saying Elvis Costello like I was
the Flexi yeah that's right but I said
but I know I've seen that picture yeah
yeah yeah but yeah so but you know the
rest of it looked okay but yeah we were
like Alan Parsons Project that's yeah
we're like what the [ __ ] is that do know
it's a little strange but other than
that the movie had a decent score I
thought the Edit was okay I had a good
comic relief because they weren't taking
a serious why should you take it
seriously the guy and his mom the
[ __ ] guy and it's like 'mom
hillbillies
there that woman man just [ __ ]
hilarious [ __ ] we're just like they just
let her go man and she is like you
[ __ ] dildo yeah yeah yes he's riding
around [ __ ] popping wheelies in the
backyard that's a streaming screen for
no apparent reason yelling at her for no
apparent reason and then he gets his
head cut off she was like and it didn't
really make sense that it was a mother
and a son because it looked at me baby
was about the same age it would have
made a lot more sense if they were
brother and sister in a relationship or
if they were [ __ ] or were they trying to
hint it like she had him when she was 12
I don't know and then what they're still
in a relationship or something what are
they trying to get out I think it would
have been better if they were just a
[ __ ] hillbilly couple well just find
they're in New York but I think they
didn't have southern accents and a lot
of [ __ ] didn't make sense so you could
tell it half the damn cast and the cops
had a bunch of goombas you know and
these are [ __ ] New York [ __ ]
yeah I'm not sure where they shot I mean
I know I know the first one and maybe
the second one were shot in New Jersey
so I miss doing that like yeah and then
they got somebody has some fake
southerners in their fake inbred self
come back with a foot of southern
souther stereotypes a [ __ ]
southerners and [ __ ] you know she was
racist he was racist against real
Billie's racist I get it right I think
it was seven I think they're supposed to
be [ __ ] rednecks right next up north
that was southern accent so yeah so yeah
just Ramone shutter they got all the
[ __ ] Friday the 13th yeah most of
them they got almost all of them
pry all the ones that matter and not
many of them matter to actually but they
do pass the time there they are kind of
funny the five did have a good score
they were trying to go for the
mainstream Steven Spielberg feel yeah
they definitely would like something out
of like you know if I can poltergeist or
something and what was with the guy from
like who looked like the dude from
DeBarge and he got killed that a [ __ ]
porta potti yeah it had a black dude in
there who's woke actually one of the
better characters and he wasn't in there
long enough they really should
and he was kind of like Rick James he
was like a young [ __ ] Rick James that
character had the same he's wearing kind
of like the [ __ ] 80s [ __ ] him
something that like member Eddie Murphy
would wear off a [ __ ] Rotter and shed
and he kind of had a Rick James kind of
haircut and he was [ __ ] living at a
van with his [ __ ] hot chick this
other hot black chick and when he got
scared he turned gay if he asked me got
so scared by Jason that he turned gay
and crawled up it scared and all scared
of gay you they have scared straight
there was a whole different I was a
whole dinner serious straight this one
was called scared gay but no I liked
that character they should he deserved
better than getting [ __ ] killed and
it [ __ ] had a bigger part in the [ __ ]
movie because he could act he was yeah I
mean it was funny compared was acting is
across the board in it all right
some of it is acting we're acting you
know some of it is kind of realistic
some of its tongue-in-cheek the tone of
the movies all over the place but it's
obvious to me that they knew what it was
that they were making well take it was
funny because we were watching it last
night on TV we weren't even drinking
last night
yeah we were just watching it and like
we're about 45 minutes into it Tom's
like is this a terrible movie like you
couldn't really decide I'm like yeah
yeah but also it's kind of like no I
said is this a bad guy was me there 10
but I could tell that every actor in
there was bullshitting me and we're half
of them were bad but they knew it it's
fun to watch yeah it's fun to watch they
knew it was bad I feel like a lot of it
was in horror movies went in the comedic
direction in the 80s like you couldn't
take it seriously I think it got to the
point to where at this point in the
[ __ ] in the series they knew what
they were making they knew that all the
other movies were like they knew some
bad [ __ ] was gonna have this movie
because it almost looked like I gotta
[ __ ]
edit it down to being a pg-13 so ya know
it is that would get if you took out the
swearing that program
thirteen so so why are they making this
movie you don't know man
seat if you are a baby if you don't have
the go right then why are they making
this movie don't bother with it so
they're just kind of [ __ ] up there I
was like [ __ ] they're bullshitting you
and you're being bullshitted and you're
watching and they're putting on a show
for you
you could tell that they were not I'm
running to City weren't taking us
seriously they were trying to put make a
good movie to entertain you they knew
that they were limited they were gonna
have to come and get it from a different
is what it was and I think that they
knew that was a b-movie so they were
gonna act like they were in a b-movie
yeah did you notice that
but everyone wasn't on the same no no
some people were dead serious yeah but
that kind of added to weirdness weird
texture to this movie the [ __ ] tone
the tone is entertaining yeah there
wasn't it wasn't a single moment where
I'm gonna say turn this [ __ ] off cuz
think about think about that were you
ever tempted to turn it off now neither
was i I never even got tempted to look
at my damn laptop yeah
so it did keep me watching it yeah so I
guess mission accomplished suppose they
weren't allowed it I don't think they
were a lot of show a lot of the gore
that they wanted to do yeah well the
Friday the 13th series for whatever
reason has been plagued since the
beginning they shoot a lot of the gore
they do this in the first and second one
as well and then if they go to get a
rating in the MPA says we're gonna give
me an X unless you cut out right so
however many seconds or however many
minutes and so they always end up doing
that so it does really seem like a lot
of the Friday the 13th movies even like
the versions that you see nowadays have
had like the balls clipped out of them
yeah this is before the time where they
had an after market where you could get
a DVD or a blu-ray yeah and it's really
just gonna sell one VHS tape it's really
funny too because it seems to me it's
like why why bother like cutting out all
that stuff because I mean the [ __ ] they
put in horror movies now like if you go
see an are horror movie now there's
gonna be some really really graphic [ __ ]
in there and it's so it just seems like
I don't know it just seems like the
standards are loosened along in those
days you gotta
the generational differences yeah people
that were running all that [ __ ] were one
they were real religious kind of like
Republicans know right and the
Republican of the 80s Republican of the
1980s who was in their 40s or 50s was
just from a [ __ ] another era
you just they didn't speak the same
language as us yeah and and [ __ ] you
know I mean it just didn't they didn't
appreciate anything that was outside a
very narrow bandwidth yeah if it was
outside that bandwidth then it was bad
that was the thinking of the time and it
wasn't until another 10 15 years they
started to age out and got replaced with
a little bit more modern people yeah I
mean cuz the people that were trying to
judge these shows that were coming out
in the 80s were probably the age of my
[ __ ] a little bit younger than my
grandparents right you know and [ __ ] my
grandparents were just [ __ ] from
another damn planet yeah you know I mean
you know yeah I want him around
yeah they would try to stop you just
from doing normal things yeah you know
don't touch that don't touch that phone
turn that internet off rot your brain
very like that yeah he was stop you from
anything I remembered you know what you
watched it what you're wearing a what
[Laughter]
yeah you speak what that's what my
grandmother heard me speak Portuguese
one time she's a UH you speak another
language I said yeah well you said you
could speak lab but you you really do
speak it so yeah she heard me talking on
the phone yeah in Portuguese this is
yeah you know and she was just astounded
I'm not sure you should be speaking that
that's the devil's tongue yeah like you
know Portuguese yeah you know those
people Ferrari everyone difficult in
Brazil yeah those people are from
another country you know that's how they
[Laughter]
it's ridiculous but that's how they talk
you never that yeah but they're from
another country or we're back they were
weird [ __ ] really weird but yeah it's
just it's funny now because like I said
you can go see just a regular r-rated
movie in the [ __ ] you know you know
the [ __ ] BIG's like Cineplex whatever
and it's like it's like a hundred times
like more gory yeah then they use then
the ones in the 80s and it's like you
couldn't even like even the [ __ ] that
they shot for the thing they like no you
got to take that out that's crazy
crazy talk but yeah so you want to wrap
up this little Monday so this is a
husband or a daily choice lash back so
her [ __ ] [ __ ] that my grandparents
are [ __ ] saying yeah good thing good
thing that they're gone cuz they'd be
calling the police
do you think they would call the police
constantly because they would think that
something was illegal it was a threat to
[ __ ] or was a threat or that's just
the way they were it was weird timing
remember how they were yeah
were you gonna wear them boots what's
that mean
you know I mean yeah what's it mean when
you wear boots like that like there's
not a meaning it's I need shoes these
are these these are Doc Martens what are
those well when you wear those what does
that mean you know man I used to get
like this not much for my grandparents
yeah um you know I remember people of
that generation yeah they always thought
like these are the things so many things
because like just other than like just
that you liked it or you liked the way
yeah and when you looked at what they
wore it was like something from the
[ __ ] 50s yes fifties and sixties it
was just yeah you had to be there most
of you guys most you guys are listener
pride too young for that but because I
don't know maybe you do remember what
your grandparents were product or their
age they were still trying to dress the
way they dressed up when they were in
their 20s and [ __ ] their twenties
they pretty much wanted to be that way
forever well when they're in their 20s
that's probably at the 40s yeah
privately probably 40 sub thirties
important thirties and forties maybe so
you know and that was like another
country back dad that was another planet
and they they weren't real good at
thinking they were very low
a very low information very low
information yeah now is nowadays you'd
call him a dumb [ __ ] but they weren't
really that dumb they could do [ __ ]
algebra and [ __ ] in their heads and do
all this [ __ ] because they were taught
all these skills they [ __ ] they they
actually could remember a lot of stuff
they're really good memories you know
they had is they didn't have any
computers so they were smart but they
were just unknowing it was just they
were just living these little tiny
bubbles yeah it wasn't yeah it wasn't so
much stupidity it was just like more
narrow mindedness because they didn't
have like a lot of exposure to other to
other different ideas or different types
of people or different ideas or doing
things and different styles of things
and different looks or a different style
you know they just real provincial no
matter where they were pretty well
they're probably real minded people they
probably somewhere in New York
California you know I mean but
everywhere else they would be kind of
[ __ ] real narrow mind and [ __ ] and
you're just trying to operate alongside
of them they come off as being a real
dumb [ __ ] like my dad you know man
Thai food you know whole [ __ ] I need add
they got the dogs and stuff this happens
- oh yeah yeah or like a plate of
[ __ ] spaghetti oh that's foreign food
yeah well it's funny because I think
we've mentioned this before but some of
the older like Betty Crocker cookbooks
and stuff like that via 40s and 50s long
explanation spaghetti and meatballs in
like the foreign foods oh yeah which is
hilarious to me and then if you read the
[ __ ] recipe the Italian yeah you read
the recipe is like man and then it'd be
like a long explanation of oregano yeah
we're a oregano zhim is an Italian spice
and now yeah and the [ __ ] this is in
there you might want to try to find this
in an Italian market somewhere yeah yeah
because they'd have access regular and
and really what the what the recipe was
telling you to make was water water in
tomato paste salt pepper a little bit of
sugar and oregano that's it I think a
little bit of garlic
I hope but that's it it would it would
have made kind of like a watery and what
the ratios are talking about like a
watery ketchup with a garlic it was just
kind of like do you remember like back
in the 70s when they have that like
pizza kit and you buy a box yeah joke
yeah it came like hold out the [ __ ] I
think you've rolled out the dough and
then like there was a can of like this
pizza sauce there's like waters like
water yeah that's what they want that's
what that's that first thing I thought
that's what the recipe I can't I
remember kind of what the bond dad but I
[ __ ] it came in a box it looked like
a damn box of uh okay this is this is
how it what a joke this ship you guys
had a [ __ ] lovers you youngsters okay
that came in a box it looked like damn
macaroni and cheese it was that same
[ __ ] size a shape yeah I had a
picture of a beautiful [ __ ] pizza in
front of it yeah you opened it up and
inside of there was a [ __ ] piece of
tinfoil and it was square my red square
pieces a foot and sides would fall down
it had a it had a package of flour with
self-rising flour and you added water to
it you made dough and it told you to
smash it down on top of that and then
you had a little bitty can alright and
you had to pop the two little things
like you know pour yeah [ __ ] sauce
out that little bitty can I was about
the size of a it was even smaller than a
dannis sausage can but half that size
and then there was a [ __ ] paper but
then there was a plastic bag of Parmesan
cheese over top didn't put that [ __ ] in
the of it and it came out nothing like a
pizza nothing like a pizza no it's
basically like kind of nothing like a
pizza cracker with some bucket crappy no
like a bread yeah bread with ketchup and
and Parmesan cheese on top of it that's
what it came out like yeah I feel like
even in like a lot of old cookbooks and
stuff where they where everybody was
like ooh canned and boxed everything
they would they would do like pizzas
like that was like ketchup for sausage
I'm like are you mental they didn't have
a good
they'd have any standards or exposures
dealing with something
from a nut you're doing with the people
that came from another planet it would
be cow like people on the country of
China
okay trying to make American food it was
that same you know what we don't have
bread so just give me a slab of that
octopus right there that's enough that's
close to bread is that for bread all
right now we don't have any hamburger so
give me some a tofu yeah put that on I
probably eat an octopus than to catch up
so give me some of that black bean sauce
and then he get to go yeah man I love
America we're doing Americans were doing
with Italian food yeah I just wanted
that all that kind of like food history
stuff I just love that kind of [ __ ] like
I said I love all those [ __ ] blogs
and you know mid-century menu and all
that kind of stuff all this like [ __ ]
old recipes you should have seen in
Mississippi but but [ __ ] my
grandparents believe my my dad's eat I
can't believe he's still alive I can't
understand everything is cooked in some
count [ __ ] bacon drippings everything
is fried and [ __ ] bacon drippings
every [ __ ] bread it you know [ __ ]
everything's [ __ ] fried I mean it's
good but you know like that every day
like that every day food is like a
religion for them yeah they just well I
know it's bad but it tastes good
it's good to have bacon grease
[Laughter]
okay yeah I mean whenever I tried not to
do that but it's like every time like
I'd go stay with my mom and stuff like
that and she always made fried eggs they
get guys to get fat I mean it's good but
you can't you like that well they used
to eat like that is sharecroppers you
know say be out there [ __ ] pulling
fields without any machines you know I
mean just a [ __ ] mule or something
and they'd be working and picking butter
beans and [ __ ] I can remember women
going out back [ __ ] pick up butter
beans yeah
remember that whole [ __ ] field of
butter beans by the house and [ __ ]
corn all right and I can I was a little
boy when they were doing that but I
remember it and you could eat like that
when you're a farmer they [ __ ] worked
hard
yeah they wouldn't fit but once that all
went away and got a [ __ ] replaced with
[ __ ] welfare checks they all got fat
and died are you gonna get diabetes
yeah diabetes the sugar yeah that's what
they call it good the sugar and then you
know and it's kind of a shame you know
anybody where the [ __ ] kind of moved
away from this real [ __ ] rural areas
yeah you know you going to Mississippi
ever suck you know every summer to visit
my dad all those kids ended up and they
were all good [ __ ] good-looking smart
kids they all left none of them good
there well you can't blame him I mean
there's nothing to do there's never to
work it's like one was they gonna do one
of them is a famous girl name famous
actress named parker posey her real name
is Missy Missy Parker Posey is her name
her dad ran a Chevrolet dealership and
her brother Chris Chris Posey they were
twins they were born together but one
was a man one was a female and he was
like Superman he's like Clark Kent and
she lived just like Lois late or
something people say that's it they both
like models yeah and in that area
Mississippi everybody was good-looking
there were just no such thing as ugly
people but they moved away yeah they're
not there anymore and what and it was
kind of like cultural genocide you know
and the main the the culture was
destroyed by one major super weapon that
the Yankees used on us MTV yeah MTV
music videos I saw they saw Duran Duran
and they saw prints and [ __ ] like that
they got the [ __ ] out of there yeah
they're like yeah we want getting out of
here
you can't like I said you can't blame
home they're done there yeah it's
nothing to do so what you done further
done you done for the day
Yeah right yeah we got a couple more
things we got a record today so anyway
so that'll wrap up our 42nd I think this
is the 42nd sidetrack show I mean it's
for 42 days mmm holy crap
yeah so have a good rest of your Monday
and we'll talk to you again tomorrow